everyone jump in the boom she was
sucking but not anymore cardi B just
dropped her new music video for press
and guys it'll leave you stunned shook
with her jaw on the floor and we're
counting down the 7 most jaw-dropping
moments starting with this
uh yeah the whole premise of this video
is that cardi kills her lover who she
just had a threesome with so there's
that
oh she's napping snap snap cardi in
lingerie a diamond cigarette in mouth
gun in hand well that's one way to get
our attention cuz this crazy number six
on our list
cardi butt ass naked yep that's cardi
topless with some strategic censoring to
make sure that it's safe enough to not
get banned from YouTube it was very
difficult to you know make the private
parts look pleasant and like cover them
up in a good way next up cardies heads
to court ensemble and like in real life
she slays the fashion game we're talking
white eyebrows a veil and lots of
ruffles I want to thank my glam team for
making me look nice with white eyebrows
and why here cardi arrives to the fake
murder trial with a posse of model
looking lawyers rocking horn rimmed
glasses wearing white the color of
purity and innocence discussing we know
what you got
carnies the heck of the immanent not
logical bank then lack of coming to time
I was really specific about that I
really wanted that look number four
more nudity cardi joins a crew of
dancers who are wearing literally
nothing but their birthday suits press
press press press press
cardi don't need multi kill them all put
them
I really wanted the choreography scene
for us we make it and then danta done
more murder the lights go out in the
courtroom and come back up to a bloody
mess but some of you get creeped because
of my street is anyone else seriously
disturbed just me okay number two on our
list cardi kills her cellmate with her
bare hands
in the toilet and I want to thank the
whole directing scene for making the
drowning part looks so dope I really
wanted to draw somebody and the toilet
and killed them cuz that's just such a
terrible way to die and they made it
happen and last but not least this
visual of cardi in an orange jumpsuit
the timing of her video is extra
interesting giving that a day before it
dropped cardi arrived in court in New
York and was hit with felony charges in
connection with an altercation at a
strip club last August cardi pleaded not
guilty after being indicted on 12 counts
including two counts of felony attempted
assault with intent to cause serious
injury the other charges against cardi
which range from harassment to criminal
solicitation conspiracy and reckless
endangerment are misdemeanors anyway
back to the video
you see God's sakes the internet
couldn't get enough and the comment
section lit up like a freaking Christmas
tree with most fans addressing all that
nudity one fan wrote producer
how many naked people do you want in the
video cardi yes another teased director
who do you want to design your clothes
cardi clothes and my personal favorite
stylist what clothes do you want cardi
leave it to cardi to have us talking
nudity first thing in the morning gosh
cardi thanks for that of course we'll be
here to keep you up to date on all
things cardi B so make sure to keep it
locked right here on e tea until next
time I'm Hallie Stevens Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]